Boom.
All right.
I love when I see something online where
I see someone who takes the idea of
fixing something or reengineering
something you're making,
it just goes so far out there.
Something totally irrational. Go.
Who is this fucking crazy guy yet?
I saw,
I think the first thing I saw was
your Bronco. Um, the uh, icon Bronco,
which is just, you took a car,
which is the Ford Bronco, the,
the 60s and early seventies versions,
which are, you know, this kind of
slight, it's a cool car.
It's a cool old car.
A lot of people take the tops off of them
and they're always kind of rickety and
funky looking and you just
engineered this thing to this,
to the nth degree with these,
these billet door openers and the way
you have this step comes out when he's,
I'm like, who the fuck is this guy? And
I'm so then I started going into your,
your website and the two
different companies, Tlc,
where you take old land
cruisers and reengineer those
and put modern engines and
suspensions.
And I'm like what the,
I just love that someone like you
is out there. Sweet. Thank you.
Cause I had no investors
that were smarter than me.
They said you're fucked our
don't even do this bad business.
But they were wrong though.
They were wrong obviously.
I mean your shop is enormous.
There's like a beehive.
People were constantly
buzzing around there working.
You've got a hundred different
projects going concurrently. You're,
you're the Bronco Build. Would you say
like a three year wait list right now?
Yeah.
We've sold 62 of them so far and delivery
dates unfortunately are running like
late third quarter 2018 which sucks.
It drives me nuts.
Is there anything that you
can do to ramp that up?
You would have to just have like four
or five of those giant warehouses.
That's part of the problem.
So like we're trying to move
and find a bigger building.
We're just about 50,000 square now
and it's all ass and elbows like a,
I think we could hire maybe three or
more guys before we're out of space.
But more importantly,
it's difficult to find those people
because kind of the idiocy of what I do is
going against modern trends and
American design and manufacturer.
So it's really hard to find people
that have the crazy skillset that,
that we require. Well, that's what really
impressed me about what you're doing.
W what,
what impressed me about what you're doing
is not just that you're reengineering
things and improving and upgrading,
but there's this,
this ode to craftsmanship.
There's this,
this passion in what you're doing where
it might not necessarily make sense.
Oh, everything we do, if you want to just
want to bring up that term practicality,
it makes absolutely no sense.
Um,
but to me that's kind of why we do it
and why I'm so passionate about every
project we do because I've approached
it from the obtuse angle of, okay,
that's how it's been done in the past.
And you know,
stock restorations are great and
they fit niche and they're right
for that guy.
Personally,
I have no patience for
archaic mechanical interface,
but I love and to just static. And
then resto shops, hot rod shops.
Traditionally they buy this piece,
that piece and kind of cobbled together
and that's cool. But I always thought,
well, you've got this convergence
of cad design, you know,
computer aided design resources and a
convergence of reverse engineering and low
volume manufacturing capabilities that
kind of are creating a perfect storm
where the stupid stuff we can dream up
an execute and make a relatively viable
business model out of it wasn't
even possible 10 years ago.
So I've been lucky enough to find enough
people that Gri with my craziness and
let me not compromise and whore it out,
but to really hold the
line and keep pushing the
boundaries and keep geeking out
further and further.
Well,
it seems like over the last year or so
I've been hearing about you more and more
and more and more. And then Jay
Leno's garage featured, uh, he,
he's featured a few of your cars.
Yeah,
we've been on Jay's show I
think four times now. What
a fucking trip that places,
Huh? Off? Just I was just
there on Tuesday. Oh my God.
It was just is what I Geek boner I had
walking around that place a willing to
keep your Chesney because what's crazy
is a lot of people don't realize the
depth of that subculture.
So Jay is wonderful in that.
He's almost become sort of a spokesman
for the niches and odd proclivities in
mechanical goodness.
But just in La alone there's tons of
dudes with these ridiculous man caves full
of wild mechanical
beasts and it is so cool.
And that's another thing like I never
had the intelligence to anticipate when I
built the first icon,
which was based on the Fj 40 Land Cruiser,
I just built it because it was keeping
me up at night and I have this idea and
after doing a design job for Toyota,
I told Mr Toyota about my stupid idea
and he kind of sort of off the record
bowed and said, go for it full,
but we won't get in your way.
So I built it to realize that
sort of model I had in my head.
Then I went back and added up
how much it costs and I saw shit,
no one's going to go for this.
This is stupid.
And I talked to some
people smarter than me,
really big brand people and
they said, no, keep it pure,
keep it what you want and what you're
proud of and you'll build a market.
So I gambled and rolled with them and
now like 30 plus percent of our clients
have two or more of our projects where
I was having a hard time getting my head
around. People would be able to
justify the expense of one of them.
Well there's so well done.
And one of the things that I was really
impressed with was just the Fj 62 land
cruiser conversions that you've done.
Like cause that for a lot of people that
aren't fans of that aesthetic or fans
of that,
that's just a regular four
door suburban type SUV vehicle.
They just,
you know,
most people would look at
that and they would go,
there it is on the big screen when they
would look at that and go, oh that's,
you know, that's cool. One of those cars.
But that's part of the appeal though.
Yeah, because it's pure
utility. There's no fluff,
there's nothing superfluous
and people yearn for that.
Cause if you look at modern cars, I don't
care what it is, longevity, simplicity,
durability, no one's thinking
about those things anymore.
They're priorities are totally
different. So a lot of guys go, hey, I,
I used to have one of those land
cruisers, man, I miss that thing.
I go to the dealer,
I look at everything,
I can buy whatever I want and it's
sucks. Everything's plastic, has no soul,
doesn't have that utilitarian route to it.
So there's kind of a subculture that'll
gravitate to wanting to go back to that.
And some of them are cool with them stock,
but more and more people
have been perverted by modern
vehicles and like could
we make the pedal on the right actually
do something and really do something
well your, your Bronco was like this
beautiful. So I mean that, that,
that shape with the
icon bumper, it's, it's,
it's so sexy to the average person
looking at it. It's sexy, but did this,
it's like you kind of have to be a fan
of that style of Land Cruiser four door
with the hatch and the back Land Cruiser,
but what you've done is like
completely bonkers. This is what,
what this is is an Fj 62 and
you call them a one 42 right?
Because you take an FJ 80 and you combine
it with the Fj 62 so what he does is
he takes his fucking thing, strips
it down to nothing. I mean you could,
you could do this way better than me.
Paul urea coats it,
media blasts it the that you,
you take this thing and make it a
combination of monitored underpinnings
completely redone as far as like weather
protection and the moisture protection.
It's like at a level that nobody ever
engineered before and then you took put a
modern corvette engine in it,
450 horsepower plus,
I mean this is bananas and you're,
you're taking this car that was
like how much was where these new,
I think they were expensive when they
were new, but that means what? 20 grand?
Probably 25 grand I think,
and engineer's him to the point where
they're 160 plus thousand dollar cars.
It's total stealth wealth,
like the natural decline of the appeal.
I find like guys will take these on surf
trips down through Central America and
not have to stress out or freak
out or worry about, you know,
the other preconceived
notions like you know,
people see you're rolling in a
nice modern supercar sports car.
And unfortunately in our culture is
a lot of guys are, I'll look at that.
Rich pricking his Porsche, right?
You know, it just gets beyond that.
So either totally invisible or you
get kind of warm fuzzy thumbs up,
smiles and it's,
it's just a whole different energy.
Well then I started
going into the sub code.
I was what wasn't aware that there was a
subculture of people that were obsessed
with [inaudible].
It's amazing.
There's so many different little
Twitter follower that you can go to.
We could see the images
that they post or Instagram.
These cars have this crazy legendary
following where people just are obsessed
with these old, like it was
this, what years are these?
These 1989 1900 specifically the ones
with the four rectangular headlights,
the Fj six two or [inaudible] 88 to
90 and then the proceeding models,
the Fj six D, which looks about the
same, those were from 81 to 87 why?
What gave you the motivation to take this
particular type of car and engineered
to such an incredible degree?
What we started with the older ones,
such a forties right? Yeah, the
forties which are really sexy,
that call, it's tremendous. It's crazy.
But we started with a 40 and then the
45 pickups and wagons and the Fj 55
wagons.
So it's just sort of the culture of
evolved in that those were so archaic
because they were earlier
standards earlier. Tokes yeah,
choke and one barrel carb. Three on the
tree and drum brakes. No power. Yeah.
So I think as these got older and the
average conditions of the ones people
could find out there
became lesser and lesser,
that market naturally extended into
these models and people say, well, Hey,
well what about a 60 what about a six to,
we're even doing the MCJ eighties doing
major rest of [inaudible] 91 to 97
versions because again,
there's a certain, um,
attachment that people will have with
them that even though the truck has gone
or it had shortcomings that still
holds a spot in their heart,
which is kind of a big part of the 98%
of the battle is already won with icon
because the majority of our projects,
we're starting with something that
already gives people warm and fuzzies.
Any of these cars have cult
followings and shortcomings,
which is kind of the perfect formula
to let me revision them and create
something like a new option for
people that appreciate it. Well,
I wasn't even a fan of these,
but I became a fan from just going
over your website and then watching the
vehicles.
I watched a couple of the videos and
Jonathan has these videos that he puts on
youtube. We put sticks, a
couple of Gopros and the cars,
and you personally take them out,
which is very good videos to suck. No,
they don't. No, they don't
suck it off. They're great.
They're really effective because yeah,
throw one of those,
like the second one down the,
that one right there,
they're not even remotely sucky.
What they are is 100% authentic.
Like when you're taking these cars out,
you're going over all the different
upgrades and different things that you've
done to them. That's when you
really start getting it. You Go, oh,
this guy's fucking crazy.
And as crazy as me at
$170,000 $20,000 car.
Yeah. And that's been a, cause
I don't have the budget, but B,
because I concur with you
that brands like these,
if they're not driven out of the vision
of the singular lunatic, then they're,
they're not worth doing.
So I wanted to keep that relationship
and personal relationship.
So although I just knock the videos
out and edit them real quick.
But I really want people to understand
the level of geekness that we do.
And well, you even leave in when you
dropped your Gopro and one of them,
I love that too. Up here it
goes, bump, bump, bump. But this,
this is the passion comes through and I'm,
I'm a,
I'm a big fan of contagious passion.
And I mean there's things that I
was never interested in before.
Like I never gave a fuck about cooking.
I loved good food,
but I'd never give a fuck about cooking
until I watched Anthony Bourdain's,
no reservations.
And I'd see the passion that this guy
has about chefs and about preparation and
the, you know, just the,
the amount of skill that is
involved in creating a perfect meal.
And then I started to get, I'm
like, oh, this is an art form.
It's an art form that I never
understood. Totally. This is an art form.
Kneeling is an art form. That's the
history of the world in a nutshell.
Anyone who's ever done a great thing,
be it important or not be a he,
a chef, a sculptor, a
seamstress, a woodcarver,
a leader,
a political figure or whatever.
It was that inner passion that drove it
and made it distinct and really matter.
So fortunately I'm feeling like I'm not
the only idiot in the last three or four
years. It's kind of like this, like
it's like there's a renaissance.
I think consumers are
tired of the big box,
luxury branded kind of bullshit marketing
facade and want like we all already
have enough crap in the first world,
right?
So if you're going to buy another
something like you with your pool cues and
you're going to buy another pull cue,
there's going to be a story to that.
Fuck it.
It's going to mean something in someone's
going to put their heart and soul on
that.
So I'm starting to see
this sort of craftsmen,
collective renaissance of makers of
people creating stuff out of passion,
not out of a spreadsheet and a vcs formula
of how well it's going to do on Wall
Street. But product first because I think
we forgot about that as a country we,
we kind of walked away from that
slowly seeing that come back.
Yeah. It seems recently. Yeah. Recently
that's become like all sorts of things.
I watched a video on this company
called Brooklyn Cut. It was another,
a manmade. The knives. Yeah, and
I was like, this is fascinating.
I never gave a shit about a guy making
dies and I'm watching this guy make these
handmade butcher knives and
kitchen knives. I was like, ah,
but you could see like the sweat and
dirt in his hands and he's going over the
edges and making sure everything's Nice.
Like Ah, there's something about that,
that I'm as an adult,
just starting to recognize this contagious
aspect and how important it is and
how when you see people
that are passionate about
things, no matter what it is,
like you said, like, you
know, make making furniture
or anything, it's, there's something
about it that gets you excited.
Like you're almost, you're pulling some
of their energy from their creation. Yeah,
the semi. That's the,
that's the perfect formula.
Because then also even if
you don't become a consumer,
their price point doesn't
make sense or whatever.
Just if you respect it and understand
where they're coming from and you in turn
are inspired to do whatever it is that
you know you've been staying in your
cubicle and earning your good salary
but your soul is dead and you start
tinkering at night, get in the garage
on the weekends or whatever it is.
I think that's key because you know
our government for decades now has been
telling us just go to target and
buy something and we'll all be fine.
Which I think is just
asinine because that was,
the country was built on people trying
new ideas and taking risk and standing up
for what they believe in and if we
just turn into a nation of consumers,
then why should anyone give a shit about
our opinion and our nosiness telling
them how to run their country.
This is another thing that I was really
struck by when I was tooling around your
shop,
which is insanely impressive and sitting
in your cars is that they'll build
quality,
like you're sitting in everything.
Like this fucking thing is
going to last a hundred years,
like all of your stuff.
And then we had that conversation about
planned obsolescence that companies are
actually engineering planned
obsolescence into their automobiles,
which had business.
A lot of people always think is like some
sort of a conspiracy theory. Like oh,
that's, you know, nonsense.
They're just trying to do the best thing
they can with modern electronics and
some of that stuff breaks. But that's
not really the case. All Shit. Yeah.
Explain to me what you
explained to me today.
Basically I think in the old days you
were dealing with products were designed
and manufactured for the sake of the
product, you know, pretty simple, linear,
pure concept.
Um,
unfortunately I would blame it on
Wall Street more than anything in that
suddenly the product in a product
company was no longer the priority.
The priority was the margin,
the scalability, the numbers
for the shareholders.
So the second you take your eye off
of the product being what drives the
company, it's going to go to shit one
way or another. So like car companies,
I mean there's stories that uh,
a certain Japanese car company whose
name I will not mention actually went and
studied, paid Microsoft
and said, oh wait a minute.
So you're a consumer buys a laptop.
When the battery dies,
you're retaining that client.
And the vast majority of those
clients aren't buying a battery.
They're buying another laptop.
Oh,
this could the business this very good.
So how racist of you by the way,
very racist. You know, I
love the whole world baby,
but it's doing it and I wouldn't,
I don't mean to infer that
this is an Asian dish,
certainly not corporate priority.
It's global is guilty as
anyone American has been.
That's been the one that people
point to because American cars,
especially like in the
80s where such shit,
they would just fall apart on a
regular basis. Yeah. So you know,
we could have a long bitch fest about
what unions have done to impact product
and viability of American manufacturer
and all that. It's another story,
but I think on the product level,
suddenly automotive brands,
we're looking at creating a vehicle
that by nature the durability of the
components within and the complexity of
the architecture to facilitate all the
perversions that we've come to expect
in modern cars automatically set the
obsolescence cycle.
So it's much better business,
although much worse for the future
to make a vehicle Wizbang nifty,
groovy designed to survive a life cycle
of a lease or warranty cycle and then
it's off to the landfill and then
what happens? Repeat consumer,
you come back and yet by another one,
Japan's taken it in other nations to and
even crazier level to promote the GDP.
It's actually hard for you to
own your car the older it gets,
your inspections become more routine.
They go from a yearly to
quarterly and on and on and on.
Registration goes up every year,
insurance goes up. This is in Japan.
It goes yearly to quarterly
to what was he goes,
I believe it's yearly to buy annual to
quarterly and then if it's a really old
vehicle, it's like monthly and
then the [inaudible] scrutiny,
like you have one little league,
oh and then you can't get your red.
You've got to dial that in. So
it's been great for, you know,
domestic manufacturing numbers
and keeping industry propped up,
but it's kind of bullshit and
shortsighted I think on a cultural level.
Well,
it's fascinating because they're known
for their door ability like Toyota cars,
especially. Honda's are the
reliability. Like if you own,
let's say an Lx five 70 which are great
trucks and modern SUV version of the
Land Cruiser, they're brilliant. They're
strong. Yeah. It'll run forever probably.
And it's super durable. But let's talk
about your touch screen on the dash.
When that bugger breaks,
you can't use your climate control
and a whole bunch of other things.
I already have an Lx five 70 and
it's the touchscreens dog shit,
but really is dog shit. Now let's flash
forward to your, you love your truck.
The warranty has expired and
that screen takes a shit.
Well that the problem is
everything is engineered into it.
Like the climate control is my point.
It's part of no labs for it now.
That part is available now
and it's federally mandated
that it must be available
for a specific window of time.
That part today,
I'm going to make an educated guess.
It's a $9,000 module for you to buy
that stupid touchscreen. Yes sir.
It's shit though. It's not good.
It's not that responsive. Okay.
So five years from now it dies. It's
out of warranty. You'll love the truck.
It's nine grant. If it is still
available, what do you do?
You likely say I fuck it and you go get
a new one back to their business model.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's disturbing that that's actually an
engineered idea that they want stuff to
break. That's not what we
want when we want to stop.
What people really appreciate
his stuff that's durable,
but your mass consumers to blame
ourselves because like I dunno,
I get in a modern car like a nice
fancy car. Uh, and, and if people go,
God, it's 140 grand this you
Porsche of blah blah blah,
but I drive it and go man,
hell on earth.
Did they get it to do all this
neat shit for only 140 grand?
That's true all the way through to
people go on to box stores and buying,
you know,
a backpack for the kids for school and
they want in 1995 or 1295 backpack.
Now granted they'll replace it four or
five times because it's a heartless pilot
poo that no one cared about
versus buying one from, I dunno,
fill center Tanner goods or one of these
upcoming passion-based brands where
maybe it's an 80 or $120 bag, but the
kid alone it, you know, for 20 years.
Right.
So I think that's part of the reeducation
of the consumer that hopefully in turn
will insight and motivate manufacturers
large and small to re prioritize what
drives design.
Are they mutually exclusive when it comes
to options like magnetic ride control
and all this crazy shit
that they have now,
these sensors that adjust to the fact
that one wheel slipping and they counter
and all this traction control and
stability management and all this jazz.
Isn't that stuff just going
to break? I mean, yeah,
I mean the traditional answer they'd
give you if you asked to, you know,
top ag engineer, he'd say, oh,
but it's all computer based.
So as is no veiling pots.
Yeah.
But their circuit boards
that take a shit and solders,
that split and code that
becomes corrupted and on and on,
a nice tire that you can change in
the side of the road, exact shits out,
you're fucked.
And the biggest issue is trying to get
those parts to support that vehicle when
you are the last of the Mohicans who's
trying to keep it on the road and keep it
going.
You know,
most manufacturers could give it to him
and as soon as they're federally not
required to maintain those parts,
they want nothing to do with them.
So it gets to a point where like there's
cars that are classic that you're
always going to get parts for.
Like you're always going to get poor,
be able to get parts for like a 70 Chevy
Nova know because people love them and
there's a big market for it. But
like a 91 civic, it's like, Ooh,
what is that? Your dumpster diving
and that's, yeah, you're fuck kind of.
Yeah, that's a, it's a
weird thing that these,
there's some cars and some vehicles
that attain this classic status and then
they'll always be classic.
But like a 2010 Mercedes,
like nobody wants that. They just don't
want it. I mean, you might want it,
it's not,
it's not a terrible car to drive.
And you can resell them in Cuba for
big money, right? Yeah. Pretty soon.
Emerging market. Yes. But you know,
I think you just got back from there,
didn't you?
I saw some of your photos.
You must have been geeked out and
all those cars down there. Stupid.
I'm surprised I didn't
get arrested though because we went
there officially is like a guest of the
governing family on a arts mission and uh,
cause we sort of anticipated less
scrutiny at customs. I carried,
my backpack had literally about 95
pounds worth of vintage car parts.
So I figured out how to ingratiate myself
with the motoring locals in our hurry,
which was amazing because I got taken
to some crazy hoards and fines of really
wild early cars because of that.
But yeah,
I brought soldering guns,
soldering wire bulbs,
relay these,
all sorts of stuff cause they,
the ingenuity,
the resourcefulness of that country
in the spirit of the people is just
phenomenal.
We've talked about it a dozen times on
this podcast because I love the fact that
they didn't have access to new cars.
So what they did is they just
reconditioned and upgraded
and fixed all their old
cars to the point where those
Yank tanks is what they call them.
Those 1950s plus Chevy's and they're,
they're just driving them
around all over the place.
The vast majority of the cars on the
road are those or recent import Chinese
vehicles because the Chinese government
kinda got in bed with them and partnered
on import automotive
distribution companies. There's,
I just wrote about it for 'em,
um,
the automotive editor for Penthouse in
the article that comes out in the next
issue, which I don't think anyone
fucking reads, but I enjoy writing them.
Someone should read a pen
house. But anyway, um,
was about that and the change in
the culture. But it's interesting,
they've actually recently passed a
federal law there that makes it illegal to
export any of these vehicles because as
they loosen the restrictions on inbound
vehicles, they anticipated potentially
there'd be a reduction in the demand.
But I don't think it's going to happen
from all the people that I talked to from
all walks of life there. It's become
like a, it's a cultural icon to them.
So, and I think it expresses a lot of
the human spirit and Cuba and how they've
presser veered and managed to make
things work with what they have.
But I mean, most of them that I
drove around in like, you know,
you'd be in a 57 Chevy Bel air convertible
and it's running a 70s Russian Volga
diesel. Really? That's actually,
I was in Castro's ex,
uh,
late sixties limousine. We rented
three of his limos and the fleet,
or didn't really rent,
but it was a friendly arrangement to
drive out a couple hours out of Havana to
go look at a very rare Aston
Martin that I knew about.
That's the only one in the country
that had been abandoned there.
That's a one of one early Aston.
So we drove these crazy old rush and
limousines to go for there and I ended up
on the side of the road twice having to
fix them. And then again, like we were,
we were going out to hear drunk at like
two in the morning and our Russian law
to taxi cab broke down.
Uh, it was pretty funny.
So I have some pretty funny
pictures of my cabby looking at me.
Just completely incredulous.
I'm underneath the car with bailing water,
cubing it up, cubing it up. So how
were they keeping these things running?
How they get access to parts?
Are they manufacturing their own
parts or they re re anything?
Yeah. I mean if for example, it's a
tourist, if you forget your toothbrush,
you're going to spend three days
trying to find a fucking toothbrush.
So where do you think you're going
to get a brake drum for a 48 olds?
So did you stay at a hotel
when you were at? Yeah,
and some people stay at people's homes.
That's a big new trend and I'd
recommend it. Same with the, uh,
the home restaurant industry
that's growing there.
The backstory to that is there was a
recent limited allowance that allowed
private individuals to
create small businesses.
So people are opening up their homes,
they're
repurposing these beautiful derelict
old buildings and opening magnificent
restaurants in them.
And well,
magnificent might be a strong word because
the food kind of sucks, but really?
Yeah. Well cause they can't,
again, they can't get anything.
So like the food that's
imported comes from,
and what the government said they could
import from who they could say it it
from. So unless the dude has his own
farm and garden and herb resource,
which a lot of them do, it greatly
limits what ends up on the plate.
But so it looks cool.
They just take people in and they have
like two seats at their kitchen. Yeah,
I think they're called Pella.
Doris I think is the word.
And some of the best meals in experience
in discussions in human interface we
had were in those
environments is super cool.
So are they or do they take like
a broken part and reconfigure it?
Did they make a new one or they,
I mean it's everything from Jb weld,
chewing gum,
duct tape and corks and coat hangers
through two incredibly gifted,
resourceful,
generally the older generation.
And I met one guy in particular in his
eighties who's very well known down there.
There's a big car club called
Friends of fun GL. So fine.
Joe was a great racer back in the fifties
who in fact one the first big Havana
rally and there's this magnificent poster
that's like the holy grail of Car Geek
posters. I still want one,
can't find it. But anyway,
the second year he went there to compete
again and Castro had him kidnapped
because they didn't want him winning
because he was an Argentinian. Oh.
And then they were like,
he can't win.
So they held him captive and apparently
treated him quite well and didn't
release them until after the race.
But this friends of find Dzhokhar club
is founded by one of the local guys who
was on his mechanic team that first year
and he knows everybody with anything
that has a motor and wheels and the,
he took me to meet this older gentleman
and this guy will not only make the part,
he'll make the tool needed to make the
damn part. So they're forging and casting.
Wow.
They're on stuff and it's phenomenal.
Like we could learn a lot of lessons
and macgyvering shit back together from
them.
Well that is one thing that we're,
we're missing and we're losing the people,
the skilled crafts from that have
the ability to make metal pieces,
which we used to be a big thing. I mean
there are people in the hot rod world,
it's a big thing.
Fabricators are very high in demand
because they do so much custom work.
But it's such a tiny,
tiny fraction. But again,
I think if we step back,
the thing that keeps me from becoming
a depressed drunk is the feeling that
that's changing.
It's becoming more important to
the greater general population.
People are more inspired and be
it in metal, be it in leather,
be it in soup, be it in cutlery,
whatever the hell it is.
There seems to be a growing trend and
people giving a shit and returning back to
that.
And I think also more importantly
perhaps feeling how it changes them as an
individual.
So like for me,
my past life I had a completely
different career and I wasn't really,
I got into it loving it and over the years
like I really didn't have the control
and creative input that I thought I did
despite putting my heart and soul in it
or a past a point despite
getting dispassionate about it.
And it starts to kill your soul.
When I was young and dumb
and we didn't have kids yet,
my wife and I spontaneously
basically quit our jobs.
And started our automotive,
the first one, TLC. I mean,
it could have totally screwed up
and not work. I'm lucky that it did,
but I think most epically
important, it, it,
it reinvigorated me as an individual.
So I am,
I'm more proud and passionate and content,
which in turn hopefully
makes me less of an asshole.
The rest of the people that I
interface with him on this planet.
So I think big cultural sense,
that's a wonderful thing that I'm seeing
and it's not unique to America. The,
the ripple effect is really,
yeah. I think around the world,
people are wanting to return to
those values. Well, and it's also,
there's something about like if, if
someone drives, like say one of your, um,
Fj forties that you re-engineered,
they kind of,
they're driving around in a piece of art.
It's not just a car that like
those volcanic black ones that you,
I mean, that's so, it's so, I mean, I
con but it's so iconic. Thank you know,
it really is it, it's your thing
like [inaudible] now it's art,
man. That's my whole approach is like it
should be, it's a functioning sculpture.
There's art. Even in the way your doors
closed, like I was, I shut your door.
I don't if she knows like in your showroom
like four or five times because it's
just so
well done. It's not, there's nothing
wonky. It's just clink, clink.
It's just you could feel that and like
I think when people drive something that
or use that guy's knives or you know,
or this clock that we have here,
it's like you feel the craftsmanship
and in Poughkeepsie on a more important
level. Yeah. Whereas like if you have like
a cool piece of electronic, it's cool.
You know, I love a cool iPhone or a cool
laptop, but I don't, I love this laptop.
I write all my jokes on him. I
do it right. All emails and jazz,
but I don't feel anything out of it.
This isn't like some guys creation.
It's not a relationship.
Yeah.
Some women didn't carve these keys with
her skilled hands and I feel it when I'm
typing no to this.
It's kind of manufacturer and it's cool
that that can be done too. But there's a,
there's another level of stuff.
There's another level of feeling that you
get from functional art. Yeah, totally.
And you know,
like the,
probably the most sort of a two
expression of that brand theology is our
derelicts, which some people
like just don't, you know,
I had ran into a guy came running
up at a stoplight this morning.
I was test driving a 54 desoto,
explain what a derelict is because people
think you're talking about bums kind
of.
So basically a derelict is where
we'll take a car with epic Patina,
like just timeworn natural decay,
but not a rust bucket.
So like a barn find, we'll take
that car, we'll laser scan it,
get it into cad, chuck the original
chassis and mechanical and everything,
and evolve that into a modern,
highly capable daily driver.
But the art is trying to make
it look like we did nothing.
So this guy had a light. He's like, you
think you're going to make it? I'm like,
yeah, I'm good because we got to
fix it up. I'm like, Nope, I'm done.
Well, what color? You're gonna paint it
red? Nope, I'm done. What? I don't get it.
So, but to me that's kind of
part of the fun. Well what these,
everyone does get it.
They look like an old car,
but you put this desoto up on a lift
and showed it to me and it's got this
insane, fully independent suspension.
And this is the, that's the icons.
But the, if you find [inaudible] are
elected will come right up. Yeah.
Um, or the derelict, not a reformer,
but these cars look on the outside
as if it's just an old car.
But then you look down the wheels like,
Hey, wait a minute. What's going on here?
And then he got kind of
like, oh, hold up a second.
You have modern corvette engines in
the just bad shit. Oh, it's insane.
Like what is this one right
here? This, that power power.
And asked her what a great man. So that
car was inspired by the first derelict,
which is mine, which is a 52
desoto wagon. So like in this,
it has a one off chassis.
We partner with Art Morrison on most of
our chassis engineering and we gave it a
gold tooth, like a crock because it had a
cavity. I was just kind of fun. But yeah,
like five 50 horse, a SRT, eight
Hemi fuel, Lee, five speed,
automatic independent suspension,
six piston, hydro boosted breaks,
Modern Climate Control, Bluetooth,
audio, blah, blah, blah.
But all like packaged in head and
so it's totally under the radar.
Totally under the radar to the point where
the knob that controls the old school
radio actually controls the volume on
this Bluetooth enabled system that syncs
up with your phone. Yeah, it's,
it's an incredible digital bit.
One Addis and not digital to analog,
but pure digital audio.
Kind of love the,
it's amazing what you're doing
is so cool because like someone,
if they didn't know and they
looked out on the outside,
they literally have no idea, but then
you would look inside and go, wow,
that is a really well preserved
interior by minute. What's that?
It just looks off. I like onions,
so if you start peeling back,
there's a lot of layers
to the absurdities in,
in building these and then that video,
and she gave me a hard time for my
hat after six had, it's all fucked up.
I thought it was perfect. That's
perfect. There are assholes.
I'll give you a hard time about everything
you could to save babies all the time.
We have too many babies.
A trill trollers used to just rip me a
new one and over the years it's gotten
better is I think people have gotten a
more thorough understanding of what we're
doing.
Well also trolls are like snake venom.
You'd get a little bit and it fucks
you up, but over time it becomes,
you become immune to it
and they actually help you.
People were like overly critical and
assholes and they actually help you in the
long run. They really do because they
make you understand that. It's just,
there's too many people. You can't just
pay attention to everyone's opinion.
There's just too many fucking people.
They just remind you that we could use
a little Darwinian trimming of the herd.
There's that, but it's
also, it's really on them.
What is this fucking thing you've got
here? This customer total shit like God,
this Si the interior was just nuts. Oh
my God. It's amazing. That's beautiful.
So that's that 50 Buick Roadmaster
convertible last on the road in 1958 we,
one of our hunters is
actually a ups driver.
Saw that in some dude's backyard and
had tipped us and we grabbed it back up.
Hold on. Or what is that? A ups drivers
to the best hunters. Really? Yeah.
We pay finder's fees to them all the time
cause they're delivering packages and
they see something covered by
leaves guys, guys, fucking car.
God,
those seats are incredible.
That one's now running a about
a 600 horse ls, seven dry some.
That card is applied now. Who's got that
thing that's a calling client. Yeah.
Remember the Super Bird, the 70 super
broom guys, former. We're building,
this is the same owner.
He's taking a superbird which is one
of the iconic American muscle cars and
putting completely modern underpinnings
that you were going to do a Hellcat set
up, right? Yeah.
Which is for folks who don't know what
we're talking about cause we're geeking
out here. Um, Hellcat
is the Chrysler SRT version,
the newest of their bad
ass challenges beast. Yeah.
It's what I drove on my comedy special,
the 707 horsepower red challenger.
It's fucking incredible.
So after talking to the creative
team in the SRT division at Mopar,
we actually learned that we're not
going to go that route. We'd like to,
but you talk about complexity in modern
vehicles without being too much of a
geek that that runs what's
called a can bus network.
So the electrical network in that car
is no longer yeses and nos x's and o's.
It's constant data stream.
So like even the dam don't light it could
be talking to the brake pedal that's
talking to the trainee.
So it makes it very difficult
to really engineer those right.
And a non native platforms.
So with SRT support,
we're actually going to the company
that builds their race engines and we're
going to do our own scratch
built scat 6.4 blown.
So we'll,
that's our performance target.
But we originally were just going to buy
one and disassemble it and repurpose it,
and we got talked out of that.
That's crazy. The all that stuff,
but all that stuff has also enabled
them to have two keys. Correct.
Which is hilarious because one of them
that you give to the valet only gives it
500 horsepower. It's like, do
you know fucking fast? That is.
It's like here, take this tone down
version, and then the other one,
the red key gives you 707 horsepower,
which is incredibly manageable.
It's really weird.
It's so all the electronics
and all the jazz,
even 10 years ago when they
would do a performance model,
they'd just shoe horned in the
biggest motor they could find.
That car to me is a great example
of change, good change in Detroit.
It is so engineered to be what it is.
It's not just throw a motor in it and
sell it. No, they, it's really drivable.
It's almost like a gt car more than it.
There's a sports car, even a muscle car.
It's like a, it feels like a
big Cadillac your ride there,
but it'll suck it down when you need it.
When you stomp the gas on
its speaking speak epic.
That duality of the two different keys.
There's an engine builder out
near our shop. This guy a motor,
it's like his trainer motor has entry
level motors like Ooh thousand horse if
that's the alien import. The alien
a Ma intake manifold guy. Is that?
Yeah, the one that Nelson racing with
her legs open. Is it Nelson? Nelson?
Tom Is evil genius but oh
God, that guy's crazy. Shit.
Dual gastic.
So you've got a toggle switch under the
dash there is dual computer networks,
dual tanks,
dual injectors.
So you've got your low output at a
thousand hearts and then it flick of a
switch,
it goes to the jet fuel tank into the
other computer network and now it's like
2000 horsepower. Yeah, that
guy built an 1800 horsepower,
69 Chevelle for my friend, the white
one. But no, it's like a light blue.
We did a white one called
on fuck with Hubble.
That's the machine.
The badges says unfuckwithable and it's
quite true other than it's probably
going to rip itself in half within
five years. Well, it's also, you know,
the first corner on the first quarter,
the 200 horsepower portion is going
to beat you. We try and not do. Right.
So although over the years
I've been pushing the envelope
with more and more and
more horsepower and it's hard to
return once you've gone there. I,
we try and never build what we call a
call to sack rides where it's so into a
corner of, yeah, wow, let's
2000 horsepower. But it
overheats. If you stand still,
it won't idle. The AC won't
work, you know, or so much power.
It's not trackable.
Trying to keep everything
we do relatively practical,
so whatever performance we have,
it's in measure with the refinement,
the trackability, like the thrift
master pickups we're building,
people keep asking for more power.
Well,
447 horsepower is what we have found to
be the maximum amount of power you can
put in it without it just being asinine
and never hooking up and just spinning
tires.
Yeah.
It seems like they might have painted
themselves into a corner with this
American horsepower war,
because when you get things like
the 777 horsepower challenger,
and then you've got the Mustang
Shelby that has six 62 and what's,
what are you going to
have five years from now?
You're gonna have a million horsepower.
What do you, what do we mean?
Where are you going to take it to? It's
going to, well, kind of like empires.
I think if you look at the history
of automotive design and trends,
there's always a kind
of a, a specific, uh,
graph of a rise and fall,
right? So I think, you know,
just as emissions laws came
in and impacted the first
air of the muscle cars and
the starting in 66 with dod and EPA,
I think you're gonna see the
same thing with these were the,
the corporate numbers will never allow
that kind of output vehicle to be
predominant because it impacts the ratio.
So, I don't know the exact numbers,
but I would fathom to say that for
every three hellcats they sell,
they would have arguably
had better business selling
26 banger versions and the
final corporate fleet,
uh,
admissions of it is such that that
thing eats up so much of their allotted
emissions, they're able to
produce that, it limits them.
So I think that should
be a great opportunity.
I think Cadillac is showing early signs
of embracing it correctly, which is,
okay, well let's get back
to craftsmanship. So yeah,
we can do this motor and
it's super sexy and all that.
But what about that plastic ridiculous
dash that we've turned into?
What about all this Foa
would, and like, Whoa, gee,
why don't we start making
more quality materials?
Which I think could be a
really interesting opportunity
because on the other
side of the coin,
you look at what the Chrysler Fiat
ownership a Ferrari has done to Ferrari
product. You'll happen a new
Ferrari. The Nav Systems,
the same thing that's in your kids
jeep Rubicon. Are you kidding me?
And the plastic stuff that, oh, it,
well it has a sexy Porsche as
well that looks like aluminum,
but it's plastic.
It's just the same thing that's in a
Hyundai or a key or anything else and I
think they better be careful to hold the
line of that quality in that tactile,
that human interface or what's the
point? It's just a badge car. Well,
they've made some pro real errors in
navigation systems and not keeping them up
update and current because if you're going
to have all that electronic jazz hip,
better, better be good to go
there. Yeah. Yeah. Like A,
I have a friend who is a Maserati and
this fucking piece of shit. Oh my God.
The navigation things.
Just dog shit.
But it's just Chrysler stuff that
some pencil pusher said, hey,
I already paid for this.
Let's stick it in the, no,
no traffic doesn't know where
the traffic is. Can Update.
CanNot reroute you like [inaudible]
come on my fucking phone does all this.
Was this why like Ferrari and
Porsche to a certain extent as well.
I actually had more respect for them when
they were making less money. You know,
when, when like the era of
the air, it lasted the air
cold like a nine, nine, seven.
Yeah. There's no nav three, right? Yeah,
no, I'm sorry, nine, nine, three. Well,
I can picture some German guy
going via not sat drive his car.
There's no couple to either
fuck you, you know, and like,
but they had the balls to say, Hey, this
is what we are. We're not for everyone.
We have a backup camera.
It's a sports car. It is
minimalist. Deal with it. Dig It.
Great. Don't go buy a Miata. We
don't care. We are who we are.
Lotus is kind of doing that. They have
because they don't do that anymore. No,
I mean the little tiny,
those little tiny one I've been hearing
is lotus just making so much money off
of licensing tee shirts and product and
crap that the cars are kind of a pain in
their ass. So the engineering arm
is still alive and somewhat well,
but the cars, I mean, they had what,
seven concepts, uh, in the last two years.
And then production viability of
any and all of them is all but gone.
It just takes such deep pockets to get
one of those coach built versions of
those cars. Like what
singers doing, singer for it.
I see guys like Robin,
I I think it's viable that if we are the
creative sorts who are smart enough to
acknowledge that we're dumb enough to
not be the numbers sorts but to build our
team and add those people to the team.
I think we can make viable
businesses out of it.
Now the second you want to
make 50,000 a hundred thousand,
300 half a million of them a year,
I think that is the bigger
struggle because I think there's,
there's conflicts at core with the
efficiencies that those business models
demand in the modern world
to be considered competitive,
et cetera. It's like, you know,
with a Ferrari talking about coming out
with an SUV because you know some pencil
pusher, stockholder of power somewhere
like we need more market share.
You need to come up with something else.
I mean even when Porsche with
the Cayenne and stuff like yeah,
it's off core, but I can understand
the business numbers made perfect sense
to grab a Torah egg and package it
up in one of those Cayenne turbos.
They're a fucking spaceship.
Yeah, it's a spaceship.
It goes zero to 60 in four seconds and
it's a fucking truck and it handles like
it's on rails. It doesn't even make sense.
It defies the laws of physics. I agree.
Same with the new uh, turbo.
A Panamera that's, oh yeah.
Oh my God. That thing's in love.
That trainee, that PDA. See,
I want to take a car like that.
Package that fucker into
an old three split window.
Three 56 [inaudible]
has an all wheel drive,
like six 60 horse PDK paddle shift.
But what does that thing weigh?
Those things didn't weigh 2,500 pounds.
So is that the amount of
power for 2,500 pounds?
That'd be so crazy. By the time you
stuff all that crap in there, it's,
you're going to be back up to 4,000 but
it's still be a hell of an e ticket ride.
It would be insane.
The is there like is there a market,
like everyone loves those old cars so
people love like 69 Camaro's and those old
school cars.
Do you think there's a market for
someone to come along and do what singers
doing?
Cause what singer is doing is taking your,
when you buy a singer car it's technically
a nine six four which is like a 1989
Porsche.
But it's not really,
it's a carbon fiber body that drive
train is totally re-engineered.
He's using his,
he Cosworth still,
I think you had a Cosworth engine so
he's got a 400 plus horsepower, uh,
air cooled like the pre, I mean air
cools kind of a stupid way to do it.
But there's the people love that sound
that the air cooled produces and it has
such a mechanical sort of
an engaging feel to that.
You know that there's that field that
those engines have that people fall in
love with.
So he's got this kind of like very niche
market or niche market if you don't
like me re butchering that word.
But is there a market for someone
doing that with an American car?
Like building a 1969 Camaro today,
like a reengineered Camaro?
Certainly.
So I think traditionally there's two
ways it's been done and there's a pending
third way it might be
able to soon be done.
Traditionally you've got a guy who
doesn't give a damn respects quality,
finds a pro builder,
and there's plenty of geeks like us out
there who do exactly what you're talking
about.
And they build six digit super freak,
super trick for that dude.
One car and that's it.
Build one and all the engineerings
applied to that one car.
Then you have the professional
quote unquote shops that Cmr kit.
So they see that car on Barrett Jackson
and it sells for two 50 and they'd go,
well shit, my friends got some
six to nine in the backyard.
I can put those together, make them
shine, and we'd get some money.
If you're talking about that guy fast
and loud, aren't ya? I don't know.
I have no personal issues
with him. No, but it's,
it's just like show people see an opera.
It's, it's more the wolves, you know,
people that see an opportunity.
So then that's like Broncos traditionally
and, and, and it's not to say anything
negative about that community, but the,
the shop owners go,
okay,
what is the perceived tolerance of
the guy who might call me and wants a
restored Bronco and right or wrong,
that may have been 40 grand, 50 grand.
So then what do they do?
They go and they try and make a feasible
business model of delivering whatever
the hell they can at that
perceived market tolerance.
So you either have the guy who won off
builds for the occasional funded guy,
you have the slightly more
commercial versions of shops,
which in mass tend to cut corners or
make sacrifices to me to perceive market
three, you've got the new breed of
fools like me and robid singer and,
and more and more guys who
throw caution to the wind,
ignore the established price tolerance,
focus on the quality and
then try and build a market
from scratch. In the future.
There's,
there's a house bill that just got
presented that has been promoted by our,
our big trade group called Sema,
which is going to really work to create
a new federal classification for ultra
low volume vehicular manufacturers
will take responsibility for tailpipes
emissions but get exemptions from larger
impact mass market vehicle crash test
certification, which makes it
impossible. But it look, you know,
we can only build 200 a year,
300 a year if that law passes.
I think people are going to be shocked
how many geeks in the fringes like us and
like us that are not branded yet that
have the engineering prowess and resources
to do exactly what you're talking about.
Like that body for 69 Camaro and
by that entire body brand new,
you can almost buy that whole car via
mail order and Lego together in Boston
over the winter. Like companies
like year one. Yeah. And,
and I think there's issues there
with quality control licensing deals,
making the OEMs and forced quality with
the license so that this emerging market
doesn't step on its own dick
because nothing fits anything.
And there's plenty of concerns there,
but bigger picture,
the capabilities of the shops and the
resources and the tooling and all this
stuff coming together.
If this law comes into play,
you're going to see an immediate new
subculture in custom vehicles built to a
very high level at a more and more
feasible price point because we'll all get
that, that scale. And like as of
today for me, when I'm these Broncos,
I'm paying triple a
day for the old bronco.
I need to restore and modify
into my final equation.
I'm paying triple what I paid before I
open my mouth and we came out with them
and they're there. It's a shrinking.
So you've kind of fucked yourself.
Totally free market. Oh yeah. Ruined it.
So if I had had the
intelligence and finance,
I would a chip Monck away a
hundred of them. Well, you,
you were talking about this before,
uh, when we were in your lot,
when you were talking to me
about how you got into business.
It's kind of on a bet and you chip Monck
the way a bunch of Fj forties and tried
to create a market. Yeah,
he explained that. Okay.
Basically I've always been a big fan
of getting out of my little box and
traveling the world and
respecting different cultures
and viewpoints, et Cetera,
sides and a lot of traveling.
I found how it was incredible how often
you'd be in a really remote locale where
a vehicle is literally life or death,
how much the people loved
the land cruisers on a whole
different level than what
North Americans dig about.
Artek cute. It's Kinda like,
it's Kinda like a safari vehicle.
Like no, like life of fucking death.
This is what gets you out of the Bush
live and people have such a deep affinity
for them. So back here in the states,
all my cars are over restored.
I want something for Fun
Dogs, Surfing Beach, whatever.
Bought an old FJ 40 like I had
grown to love on a, on a prior trip,
geeked out and restored it,
et Cetera.
So I was at a business
class extension class.
I didn't go to college at USC and we got
into a debate over supply and demand.
Me and another student and the professor,
my theory was supply and demands bullshit.
Cause if nowadays if you control the
supply you couldn't create the demand.
They said I was an idiot back and forth,
turn it into a bat and I was given,
I think it was six months to drive a
trackable market up 30 points and I think
it was like a thousand bucks
bed or whatever. So um,
although I was still active in my prior
career in my spare time and was spare
money,
I had already invested in
a couple automotive shops
just because I was already
wrenching and restoring stuff in my
garage and helping these guys with their
business model but using their resources
cause I didn't have a lift in my shop
and my house.
So yeah,
went out and bought every FJ 40 worth
the rat's ass that I could find.
I did find you perhaps through,
I think about four 30
probably about 30 of them,
30 of them in six months. But
this is like thrifty nickel. No,
that was like two months real.
Yeah. Oh my wasn't working.
I would say just road
trips rampage by 12 or so,
and then I call the transporter and
coordinate and send the 18 wheeler to go
pick up those 12 and then keep going
called the other transport or pick up the
next 12 and then chip might come away.
I didn't geek out at first.
All I did was fixed the problems.
They had clean them up really well
and then bring them back to market.
And this is in the day of the recycler
and the thrifty nickel and all that.
And it was like shooting
ducks in a barrel because hey,
culturally people dug them,
but there wasn't like a cult around them
and nobody was restoring them worth a
damn.
They would like throw Leftover v eight
and a $20 paint job and chrome rims from
their brothers,
El Camino or whatever.
No one was treating them
like conventional classics.
So that was just very simple
premise of give them more respect,
represent them better,
bring them back to the market.
I betcha there's a bunch of men and
women that dig them who aren't engaging
because of the quality level,
what they see.
And then luckily I was right and I went
back for them to pay me on the bet and
no one would pay me. They wouldn't pay,
you know the best. So what did they say?
It was just a joke dude. Just a
joke. You 35 cars fun as all hell.
I made out like a bandit. I've made,
uh, when you, when in fact those cars,
the profit from those cars let my wife
and I piss off and go to South Africa for
like three months and have a killer
vacation when we were young and single.
And that's the vacation where we're
lamenting these dude's never pay it up.
But I'm like, but I think
there's something there. And
honey, you hate your job.
I don't really like mine
anymore. Fuck it. Fuck it.
Fuck it. I love these stories over hits
low. We get home. Let's just quit. Yes,
we're like, we were in our twenties so
we quit. I took like three credit cards,
20 grand,
my quiver of trucks,
a wing and a prayer took over my friend's
lease cause he wanted to move his
classic car shop to Santa Monica.
And literally like we put a post it note,
it was like 1200 square feet. I put
like, I dunno, five or six trucks,
glass window in Van.
I put the trucks in the window,
put a piece of cardboard on the door,
my cell number,
and I'd carry around my old Motorola,
you know, Tan brick cell phone,
just go about my life.
And people started calling it
just like third truck we sold.
We sold to a dude who's like, hey, if you
ever heard of the Internet, we're like,
yeah, we heard about that. Sounds like
what you're saying, these six, oh,
that was barely write and be
like, well, it sounds pretty
wild, man. He's like, yeah,
well I designed websites are
like, cool, what are those?
So we actually traded the FJ 40.
We sold this guy for a website.
Wow.
It was just, again, serendipity, uh,
has been so good to me that just shows
you how insane technology has changed in
just a short amount of time.
We have,
one of our sponsors is company
called Squarespace and you,
you can make a website,
no bullshit in about 10 minutes.
And it's a bad ass website, drag and
drop. If you have a series of images,
it's so easy to do for
building online store.
You got to trade a fucking car
for a website nowadays for like I,
we're redesigning the icon site, it's
going to go live in a couple of weeks.
And being the geek that I am like,
I'm like didn't want to Redo it.
Our current sites, okay, no one's
pitch and it gets the job done.
But apparently it's written
in some language of some
company that got bought by
someone who got bought or got shelled
by the last guy who bought them.
And then we got a notice that like,
well you know what?
Browsers could be tomorrow.
It could be in a year,
but literally like a light switch,
my site won't be decipherable.
I'm like fuck. So if I'm going
to do it, I want to do it right.
So my director and I spent like eight
months geeking out and researching all the
automotive sites, which I, you know,
got a lot of ideas of what to and what
not to do and my program or I'm like
Mister America for manufacturing,
but my programmers in Afghanistan,
so other than my server freaking
out and then wanting to blog,
you're getting hacked from Afghanistan.
Once we got that cleared up,
this dude is a rockstar from Afghanistan.
He's got like 20 young employees.
He's fresh out of college.
All of his employees are college kids
were paying them way board then they're
used to making locally,
but 10% what I was paying the fancy
pants agency in New York that to the old
site. Wow. And overnight,
like I'll give them all the notes and
we'll do the layout at like 5:00 PM I come
in at work, like there'll be
an email, it comes in at 5:00
AM boom, boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom. Everything's done.
Dude, get me this guy's number rocks
the house. Jesus fucking Christ.
I'm down with hanging out with Afghanis.
I loved that.
I love that kind of strategy.
I love the fact that you just went for it.
I love people.
Go for it.
Don't sit around and fucking hate
your life for the next two days,
decades and Afghanis just yet again.
Another example of a guy who's like,
there's no opportunity here. Life sucks.
I don't like my job, but wait a minute,
maybe I could do programming for,
for you know,
the guy followed his
passion and yet again,
he's doing a great job in succeeding
commercially and personally because he put
his heart and what he dies
and it does a good job.
Yeah, there's anywhere
it's possible and I love I,
one of the things that's
come out of this podcast,
it's been a surprising and amazing is
how many people have done the same thing.
How many people that have listened to
these podcasts and God and listen to
people like you talk and just spread
their passion. Go fuck it. I'm doing it.
And then just figured out a way to do
it on the weekends and nights after work
and then put it together and
then get a viable business model.
I tell you,
well,
when you and I are 80
and we're not producing,
maybe we can't do anything anymore and
we sit back and we think about our lives
outside of family and and and the
people in our immediate circle.
I think the thing that we're going to
carry the longest term true pride about is
having in little ways or big inspired
other people and made a positive impact
and just like that,
like the fact that this
podcast you probably when you
started that cow, whatever,
okay it will be a side thing on and
get rolling with it but it's turned in,
it's created an entire community and
it's inspired other people like I've,
we call them our COO, my kudos
emails. So just being a goober.
If I'm on a blog or I am listening to a
podcast and I hear of another craftsmen,
I don't care what he's doing.
Like the dude with the petrified
wood I was telling you about earlier.
If I find there's somebody out there
following their dream and they're doing
something that I think is killer, I'll
figure out bigger, small who they are,
where they are. Get their email
and I always send out an email,
my subject lines always
Kudos and it's just dude,
good for you. Well done. Pitch and
go forward. Proudy of that's great.
And they're honest and they have
to be or this wouldn't happen.
But it has turned into so many
friendships, opportunities
and relationships,
collaborative projects like
it just, it's good, warm,
fuzzy karmic. And for both of you, when
the guy receives that email, that is fuel.
That's the reason I started sending him
is because I started getting them and I
noticed how it impacted and empowered
me to stick to what was important.
And it's everything that, the thing
you were telling me about is that,
is that going to have a website? The
stools that he makes and the, the,
the tables in the mix only seen him on
Instagram. And there's another one. Uh,
tell me where it is again. What is the
name on Instagram? This, I got to find it.
He's using petrified wood,
right?
It takes petrified wood and then through
the cracks and the petrified wood,
generally like a trunk Helen
bed diodes in the thing.
So like at night it like bleeds
light and is like organic.
There's this other dude who's in,
where is he?
He's pedago way.
I think the guy takes gourds and he carves
them in the most incredible filigree,
intricate way.
Turns them into ceiling lights.
So they broadcast this most incredible
spectrum of shadow and color and like
it's a,
it's a fucking cord.
The guy turns it into just like out there,
there's the,
the Sanchez brothers or family,
three generations. Okay.
This Mexican dudes in New Mexico
or Arizona and I think New Mexico,
now they have state licenses
to pick up firewood.
So they're out in the old growth areas
in the desert competing with dudes who
are looking for firewood,
but they're looking for fallen old
growth timber or standing dead.
These guys take these pieces of wood and
we'll pick up turquoise and metals in
that same area.
They literally take them
back to their studio.
And I don't know about the older
generation, but I've met the youngest.
He'll sit back and stare at that would
roll a fatty and burn it and get intimate
with the shape of the wood.
And it can sit there for an hour or
five years until one day he's like,
Oh yeah,
a chair.
And he like sees the
vision of the shape in it.
So they do like bowls and trays
and staircases and tables and shit.
Gene of his would take
Fletcher's Instagram page.
He put up this insane table that
someone did along those lines.
It looks like it was carved out of a
single block of wood and some guy had this
really unique idea for
the side of a table,
like the front seat. When do it, what
was the guy's name that made those,
uh, the, the table too. I don't remember
the gourd or the table. I suck with names,
but I'll, I'll email it to you. I wish
we could pimp them on the show. But
in another guy like that, there's a guy
on disability in Detroit who was, uh,
increase the most gifted welder.
I've PR. I'm a damn good welder.
And this guy's a rockstar. So his
name's Josh Welton Brown dog welding.
He no longer can work because of these,
have these massive surgeries in both arms.
Fuck.
But to just to keep himself
alive like his spirit alive.
He started doing artistic
efforts with as wells.
So this dude literally takes
scrap metal or old shovels,
hammers them,
messes with them.
Repurposes them and s does
these incredible sculptures
out of scrap metal water,
no dogs and cars and whoa
that tables the table.
The kick ass. Yeah it doesn't,
I don't think he put a source.
No look at that though.
It's like it's all one giant block of
wood and I think it probably is sectioned
off on the left side that we can't see.
It's hard to tell but on the right side,
the side that's facing us,
it's sort of like steps like
you know what it looks like.
He took in cuts of posts,
beams like for buys and sectioned them
in to like a butcher block pattern.
Like guys who are doing that with
walls to where from like a paper,
it's exactly what it looks like.
Right?
It doesn't fit with your printer hub
of the wood that they don't use for the
paper pulp and you leave him at dis
similar lengths and you put them at 90
degrees on a wall and you do a whole wall
of and cut tree limbs look super cool.
We've been doing more and more hardwood.
There's a company called urban hardwoods
that sells tables like that. Jamie,
she would pull pulled out,
set up and they essentially,
they take really cool old hardwood
chunks and make them these really unique
tables.
They're not perfectly smooth.
A lot of them have like see if you
go to the gallery, if they have a,
you could see some of their,
some of the stuff that they do,
but then they kind of do this on a large,
a fairly large scale and they go all over
the world or all of the country rather
to find chunks of wood.
There's also like a auto aero art,
I think it's called,
or aero art.
The Dude's that take airplanes scrap and
repurpose it into furniture and stuff.
So cool. Yeah. Well, this kind of, yeah,
the here you see these guys
actually taking the wood itself.
They'll have giant cranes carry
these logs. It's brilliant.
My Buddy Eric is a a
pool cue manufacturer.
He's like one of the most
sought after in the world.
He runs a company called sugar tree cues.
It's all completely handmade,
all his own and he's one of those guys
who will drive around in his truck and if
he sees a log like off the side,
like he lives in New Mexico,
he'll drive like a mile into the desert
and figure out a way to chop this
fucking iron wood into the back
of his truck and then make these
pool cues with it with the most detailed
figures on mother nature has an inland,
just let the natural Turkey,
he'll,
he'll do points like he'll cut pieces
together but he doesn't like inlay.
Like some people they'll,
there's different styles of cues.
Some of them they'll inlay like abalone
are little pieces of bone or what?
Mastodon.
Ivory is one that he uses occasionally
for like the joint like 10,000 year old
mass did it because apparently
that's super prevalent.
Like you can find a lot of that stuff
and it's actually been growing because of
the crackdown on elephant ivory
that is actually created a,
a strong market spike. I was just learning
that and Africa last month, you know,
but I used to do fine furniture, um,
as a highlight. I used to sculpt,
paint pre-raphaelite style, do
woodworking. I did leather working,
but these are all hobbies,
just different things I'd explore and I
actually gave a couple minutes thought
of making a commercial go of my furniture,
but it was like add up the hours.
Like no, not going to happen.
Like all quarter Sawn White Oak.
I'd fume it instead of standing at,
which is like way old school way of
doing it. That makes no sense. Hume,
what does that mean? Fuming? You
basically create like a desiccant chamber,
like a sealed chamber and
you put a desiccant in there
that sucks all the oxygen
out of the year.
So that in turn surface cures the wood.
And the longer you leave it in there,
depending on the type of wood
and the coarseness of the grain,
it'll impact and stay in the wood.
So like early Stickley,
Gustav Stickley Furniture, arts
and crafts era stuff, most of that,
a big part of its durability is
not just that it's quarter sawn,
but that it's fumed ammonia,
fanny desiccant ammonia is what's
traditionally used. What does the,
what does desiccant,
what does that mean? Um,
I believe it's the process of extracting
oxygen and moisture and that's what
ammonia does.
Yeah.
Why you try and take a breath and your
desk and chamber when you're doing
something you're so unfilmed it looks
like maybe like a white oak and it gets
down to black at 32 hours.
Yeah. And they're dreaming.
It's not that calculable.
It depends on the size and the grain.
And you literally,
you put it in there and you make it
clear so you can just check on the bugger
and let it sit in there and darken up
until you find that sweet spot they need
is take it out and surface,
wax it or wireless and you're done.
And if you get a gnarly,
uh, scratching it,
that's not just on the top of the grain,
it permeates and really nice and deep.
So like that thrift master you saw,
that's old Puget sound,
sunken logs brought back up,
killed quarter sawn and
processed and fumed.
But then we do a marine Matt seal for
durability because of that, you know,
being a truck bed. But so I still
get a little bit of time to,
to have fun with hardwoods.
We integrate them sometimes.
Well if you decided to do that and put
the same passion that you put into icon,
I'm sure it would be just as big success.
It's just one of those things. People,
I mean I have,
the market's not as big I guess.
Is it more people probably buy cars? Does
that make none? Doesn't he make sense?
People buy tables,
chairs, couches and shit.
It's just hard finding something cool.
If you want to put like a cool piece
of furniture in your house, good luck.
You'd have, you know, there's
some stuff that you can get it.
Retail stores like restoration
hardware has some pretty nice stuff,
but it doesn't, yeah, he raised,
you're like someone just farted.
That guy is screwed.
More heritage brands and designers,
he'll steal your design,
lock,
stock and barrel and take it to market
weight to come after him and go, yeah.
Sumi real ambig.
Uh,
they did a horrible thing with the guys
that originally designed the famous
American navy aluminum tall chairs.
They just stole it, went to market,
had it made in India or whatever.
But that's actually a very cool story
for people that care about these things
that it's worth looking into. And they
no longer republic lead comment on it.
But there was a settlement and the owner
of, what is that Navy chair company?
There's southern cal
company been around forever,
I don't know since like the
forties. But anyway, he said,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
you're not going to screw me. Just
cause you're a big, and I'm little.
And he leveraged everything he had to do
and did a big campaign to be made right
and protect it.
So they that the courts
upheld his complaint,
shutdown restoration hardware's effort,
made them pay damages and they protected
this guys designed and trademark and
brand shouldn't just be damages
when someone plagiarizes
like that or steals it,
don't even get me started. Trademark
infringement, copyright violation.
We go to trade shows and see designs that
I penned and developed and did the cat,
did everything myself and house.
I've seen the exact product, lock,
stock and barrel on a supplier's
booth at Sema for sale retail.
There's no way that guy say, dude,
what are you doing when you call me?
You got my cell. Like you can make
that so much cheaper than I can.
That would have given you my files.
We could have worked something out and go,
hmm, yeah, that's business and
this. What do you sue them?
How do you do deal with that? No, I
licked my wounds and walk away. Fuck.
I just learned a lesson and go fucking
humans in business that but not all.
Just a few like hunts.
There was,
there's a rickshaw driver in Havana that
I realized after I'd given away all my
car parts,
I had a tire patch kit still my backpack.
And I remember this kid we had, we had
had a conversation, I speak Spanish,
we'd had a conversation early
in the trip and like Ah,
he'd appreciate that cause he
had been telling me like the,
the mafioso that you know,
runs the ric shawl rentals,
just like in the Greek New York cab deal.
If he gets a flat,
he's got to bring it back there and they
charge him some ridiculous rate to fix
the flat and it's on him. So I, Oh
this kid will appreciate my kit.
So late at night I find him, I give
him the kid, he's stoked, takes me out.
We just go for a drive and a
talk and he nailed it in broken
English. She was saying the
difference between Communism,
socialism and western capitalistic
driven things. It's like, you know,
there's values in them all and
none of them work independent.
And perhaps the perfect cultures of the
future would be a fusion of socialism in
certain respects. Such as, you know,
education and medicine would have you
and but also the free market capitalist.
He goes, but the end, he was explaining
to failures of each and he nailed it.
Capitalism has no conscience.
And to me that that's it.
That's it.
If we can figure out a way to still
have brands and products and consumerism
that has a conscience both to
its consumers, its shareholders,
the environment like just to wake
up awareness, not this me, me, mine,
Mine, mine, then that would
be cool. It isn't it the cat,
the idea of capitalism is sort of
independent of the human being.
It's like the idea of capitalism,
this idea of eternal growth that's
sort of independent of the human being,
but the human being practices,
capitalism.
So it's up to the human being to have
conscience. So I think it's maybe I'd,
I'd prefer to hope that what you just
described would be corporate TISM if that
was well, right, like a corporation,
I can understand having no conscience
and then it's up to the individuals to
hold them to some level of accountability.
Yeah.
And I also please go just money for
the sake of money and capitalism as a
priority. I think if we could put that
in check and reset those priorities,
I think it would serve everyone
well on many different levels,
but also I think that but what do I
know? I'm just some fucking mechanic. No,
don't you dare do that.
You're dead on.
And I also think that it could be taught
whether it's just primary education or
whether it's being taught at in business
school that when you steal you're not
going to be happy. You're going to know
that what you did. Is it legitimate,
you're a fraud totally.
And that these, no,
there's no way to go round
really relevant and important,
which goes back to accountability.
Do you mean do something stupid?
Now I turn around and sue somebody. It's
like, well you did something stupid.
Whatever happened is saying, oh, I fucked
up it. Just being accountable for it.
Look what happens to authors when you,
you hear about an author or writer,
a plagiarizing and they get caught and
then someone takes their work and shows
the, the original and like, look,
there's 50 different examples of this
guy taking full passages from these books
and, and repackaging it as his
own. That guy's done. Yeah,
they're fucking done.
And that's essentially what these people
are doing to do in the same thing when
they get called out, they kind
of, they pay the lawsuits and the,
but they're allowed to keep practicing.
And that if we treated those companies
the same way we treat those writers,
then things would really change.
And people looked at restoration
hardware and went, oh, you did what?
Oh fuck. He goes, yeah, I'm going
to design within reach. Yeah,
it's more expensive.
But they work
with these companies. The problem
is that history, it's a location.
There's a big building.
You'd go there and you know,
I need a fucking couch catalog and
the like, those aircraft chairs,
I'm damn jumped it. I am too.
But I'm like, not. Once I
heard that story, I'm like,
I can't do it.
Can't support.
What you'd need to do is hire someone to
rip off their design of their air craft
chair. There you go. Beat them
at their own game. Fuck. I mean,
is that real? I mean, can you do that?
I can't think you can get
tapped though on education. Um,
I think that's another thing that,
uh,
is so important and misguided.
You know,
suddenly blue collar is a bad thing.
Well, I mean, I've got a neighbor who,
a plumber, he's doing fine.
Don't worry about him. Yeah,
you can meet a lot of money,
blue collar.
And I think that our school system,
not,
not only not supporting that,
but not educating kids on the Plethora
of opportunities in the world for careers
and the importance of loving what you do
versus expecting people to fit in these
silos of doctor or lawyer
or where's she at the,
I'm going to take a two second half
cooked idea and I'm going to sell it,
become an internet billionaire with
good luck with that. But it's like,
it's like the Palae dreams of the
Brazilian kids. Like, oh, okay,
but I hope you got another plan.
But we're not even,
we're not even teaching kids how to write
a check and balance personal finances
in school,
not to mention showing them the
opportunities the world has and help them
identify what they care about.
We just kick them off to college where
they party for two years in a hopefully
on their own,
find something that matters to them or
they continue doing whatever they thought
they were supposed to be doing and don't
discover what they love until it's too
late.
And if they get any inspiration from
their teachers or professors are going to
get these little nuggets that they have
to nurture like little embers the night.
It's not like a constant, not a
cultural education. Yeah, I think it's,
Norway does a kick ass thing where I
think it's 10th grade you do an internship
with like first they sort of give you
the big picture and then you can pick
where you want to do an internship and
then you do it and then your final year
in high school is preparing you for the
career future that speaks to you that
you've already identified.
So when kids go into business right
away or off for further continuing
education, they care about it
and there were already engaged.
They're not just getting kind of churned
through this system where they don't
even know what the hell they want to
do. So. So it's just making money,
charging them for a debt they'll carry
through their professional career. Well,
it's also hard because the teachers
are so unmotivated here, so it's,
it's so difficult to get people and pay
them like a poverty wage and expect them
to be enthusiastic about
presenting limitless
possibilities to these kids. Well,
they don't even have limitless
possibilities in their
own life. They're fucked.
And some shitbag $40,000 a year job that
has a complete ceiling on it as far as
growth potential and as far as the
appreciation that people have for what
they're doing. And that's
something I struggle with. I mean,
I pay over market in my world and none
of my people make what I honestly think
they should.
But if you look at the business model of
it and all the ridiculous cost of doing
business and scale in America,
not to mention California it,
it's like the business that I,
you know,
I see guys go to China or wherever
they go to make something feasible.
We can bitch about that all we want.
But if we look at the entitlements and
taxes and all the crap that's developed
around, it's like I di, I think these guys
should make double what they're making.
Show me the business model.
Like literally I've been searching for it.
I just finished reading a great book
called Spark, which is about Lincoln,
which is one of the earliest is
still one of the predominant welding
manufacturers in America and this guy
was doing revolutionary stuff with
employee retentions and like he was
paying out such big bonuses that the bonus
is generally we're 110% of the
salary to all employees at all level.
He would basically at the end of the year,
look at whatever the,
whatever the taxable profit of the
company was and disburse it as bonuses.
So you have to pay the tax and the IRS
got pissed and investigated them several
times, but it held up.
But now they have a proud,
educated,
healthy workforce,
some of which had been
there for three generations.
There are multinational company,
they've managed to stay progressive,
competitive and dominant.
Having this model of this pay structure
in this community that goes against what
every economist that, I mean there,
this book is still one of the,
it started as a Harvard case study and
it's become the most common business case
study ever in North American universities.
From what I understand.
And is it duplicated?
Is anybody tried to replicate what
they're doing and there's been different
efforts but not to the
extent that they have.
And in fact they failed with it and other
nations because there become cultural
conflicts with the viability.
But like I'm studying that,
like what could I do that we make
that work. But you know when you're,
you know, California Shit, we're busy.
We've got a one to five year
backorder on all the different icons.
If I wanted dude's let's work harder.
Let's come in Saturday. Let's,
I'll work Saturday. Everyone
came. It's not mandatory.
It's up to you, dude. I, okay.
Over time is one thing and
that's fair and reasonable,
but all your workman's comp and all
your insurance is an everything rise
exponentially based on you doing that.
So like waiting a year,
d incentivizing me to
give my guys bonus income,
increase our productivity and therefore
the productivity of the nation on a
bigger impact company.
Not My little
stuff,
but it makes it disincentivize
you to create more.
It's more costs on top.
It's hilarious that they were investigated
by the IRS for generosity. Yeah,
basically. And it took him years
and years, but they, they want,
hey look, it's so gross. You have
to fight the fucking government.
Like who are you? Who are you? Yeah, you,
you aren't you guys supposed to be
just protecting us from fucking war?
What do you do? What are you doing?
You're investigating generosity. Yeah.
No, nothing but fun. It's so bizarre.
We didn't bore the car geek cannot hold.
No, no. I think you have a wider reach.
These, these, these people are,
they're, they're, they're loving this.
This is great stuff.
This is fuel.
Do you get a hard time to bring
it back to the car stuff too?
Like the Desoto that you showed me too,
which is just fabulous.
Do you get a hard time from people
that want to keep everything,
numbers matching those Fuckos,
those goddamn crazy there,
whatever the world,
and I'm okay with it. I just, if they
call me, I'm first one to go, dude,
you're talking to the wrong guy.
There's a desoto specialist in Kansas
that we'll do it down to the factory
imperfections and chalk marks that
you love so much and joy. I mean,
the way I see it,
Henry Ford was kind of a prick,
but he was a genius and he said a couple
of clever things. My favorite being,
there's an ass for every seat,
so I don't expect what I do
to make sense to everyone,
nor do nor that should be a two way
street. So there there's a place in that.
I think that's a dying market.
I think that guy's somewhat
of a dinosaur in our market.
People expect it to evolve, but there's
a finite number of those to Soto's.
That's the argument against, but they can
eat me. I mean that's a station wagon,
which traditionally no one's given a
shit about. They were work the hardest,
thrown away wet. No one cares. They
have the least amount of parts support.
They're the most expensive to restore
with the least return if you look at it as
an investment.
Here's a perfect example.
I have a 1965 corvette and my neighbor
has a 1965 corvette and my neighbor was
driving up the hill in his car while my
car was being returned to me from Steve
Strope at a purely shave. Yeah, he's
the one who builds my car. He's nuts.
I love him. He's the best. Um, Steve, uh,
my car is not stock at all
and this guy is bone stock.
This guy just ready.
It looks at you like you're just a moron.
Looked at me like I tried to feed Ted
Nugent a Tofu Turkey. It was a really,
the look on his face. He goes,
what? He goes, what is that stock?
And it comes out with this fucking 35
series rear tires and like ruined it.
He looked at me like I was a total,
it's not even nothing stocked.
I the only thing that stuck is the panels
the the entire frame or at least stock
anymore either? No, he actually got
it from, I got it from our motors and,
and then shipped it to him and he did
all the extra work to it, but the,
the underpinnings and
everything was already done.
He's quite the craftsman. Oh,
he's a bad motherfucker. He's in it. He's
a mad man when it comes to that stuff.
But the point is this guy,
but those cars are sort of precious.
So 65 Corvettes are precious.
There's a finite number of them.
And he looked at me like, what the fuck
did you do? I've gotten hate mail. Yeah.
I've got a couple cars in the line that
we're going to do soon that are really
going to piss off the purists. But I
gotta tell Ya, it's part of the fun.
To me that's 63 Ferrari or
we're going to build, oh my God,
the Ferrari East does urgh just
going to lose their shit over it.
Whatever. Yeah. Ferrari. Easters Dana
White, my friend who owns the UFC,
one of the president of UFC. Dana.
Yeah. He wanted an Fj for a while,
but he didn't like the wait
time. He disappeared on me.
Yeah, that's Dana Heath.
He wants things guest today. What do you
got? You got anything right now? Let's go.
Um, he has a test to Rosa and uh, he
always wanted a test to Ross and as a kid,
so he got some money,
got to test throw. So,
but he had the interior
completely stripped out and
he had everything completely
redone,
like modern stereo system.
Totally new upholstery and people
who have found out about it,
but just appalling, I think even
changed the wheels. Just how dare he,
but you can't do that where you can do
it with other cars. It's sort of like,
even with Porsche's, you
know, the r group, Porsches,
they would take those scaled
out laws have become acceptable,
like Magnus Walker's conditions.
Yeah. I love that guy too.
He's a character he's been on here. Um,
you know what? There's three Ferrari's,
his own for rise.
You don't do that.
They don't do that with
also with Rolls Royces,
which you're going to differ is that I've
done, I've pissed off the rover guys.
This is the best vehicle ever. How would
you've ruined it? I'm like, well you,
what you did unfortunately was get
peoples dick hard for something that you
don't want to do again because you,
one of the things I asked you about it
right away, I was like, got defender.
You're like, nope, nope, nope. Don't
do it. That's fucking do it. Don't,
don't fucking do it. Do it.
If I cannot speak reason,
pull out time defender video.
Put a icon.
Defender one ten one 10 is
colored in the night. Oh my God.
It's a fucking work of art. It's a
beautiful, beautiful cause. Suck.
They're beautiful. But like whoever's
sketched, it was a rockstar.
Whoever executed it was an account.
Everything that could be compromised
was comparable. But as you said,
in my opinion, these are
essentially, they were,
they were just utilitary vehicles or
utility vehicles, agriculture vehicles,
and they get great for what they were,
but they don't line up right.
But it wasn't a priority. What do you
think about like west coast defender,
you know when he's doing,
he's taking these things and kind of like
re rebuilding them from the bottom up.
Um, just a different kind of
thing. Totally different thing.
He's more respectful of the original.
The most established company with that
approach is called East Coast rover.
He c. R they're held in the
highest regard with a tradition.
The the west coast
dude. I haven't met him. I've seen him
very nice. Got some media, good guy.
But I don't know the
depth of their expertise.
I do know that that car is a disaster
because so many people had been importing
them and calling it
older than it really was.
And then there's crazy stories out there.
I mean the federal government has seized,
I think 60 68 of them were,
they destroy the destroyer, which
is fucking crazy. If it's out,
if it's past like 95 I think
they've been in the right,
but then it turned into a cluster fuck
because of the story I heard was that
when they were confirming by Vin
number with Land Rover corporate,
they were only for privacy concerns giving
land rover the last six digits of the
ven. So rovers like, oh yeah, now
that's not an 80 full, that's a,
that's a 2002 well the repeated the Vin,
the last six digits cut
repeated through the decades.
So a lot of these cars were
stolen and not stolen, seized.
And in some cases erroneously
scrapped whether they want illegal.
So I don't know.
The ones that I built,
I'll only use a u s model cause I don't
want anything to do with that shit show.
But I have to have much important,
we're actually importing a 1946
[inaudible] from France this week.
What does a Simcoe, it's, it's uh,
wealthsimple Sitka I believe was owned
by Ford and they built all sorts of stuff
under license.
The car that we're going to do as this,
it's like a funky two door woody version
of the Fiat top Alina that was licensed
to the French market to be made by
Sim. So, but that thing's so old.
It will be easy to import. This video
just totally gives me a boner. Well,
what you've done is create
like the perfect defender
but you don't want to do it
again. I mean this means he doing
but it still wasn't perfect,
which is what bugged me. But it
has a design game. Beautiful Look,
pray,
but it's not,
it's like it's got this manly
utility that's a lot to it.
It's just,
it just makes you want to own it and it
makes you want to drive around in it and
deal with all of its quirks.
It's so that means some,
it's the shapes that just become so
satisfying for whatever reason. Nailed it.
The shape on them is just
magic. Everything. The, the
bulge that the hood has,
the fender flares. I like how you
have in a different color, like a,
I like how you repurpose the events
and you know, redesign the site.
Actually work because they didn't
do anything before a whole. Yeah.
And there are plastic and you use
twisted parts too. Right? Okay.
They get some good work to quality. But
which she did, man, this is amazing.
He fucking, you need to do this more. You
do, I'm sorry. You need to make these,
this would be as big of a seller
as those Goddamn Broncos. Yeah.
But I can't get the bodies.
And the other issue is the way
the bodies are built there,
their angle iron with
aluminum riveted to it.
So like boat builders of known not
to do that since World War One.
So the rest themselves from the inside
out. There's nothing I can do about it,
but can't that be done again, like
the way you do your FJ forties. Um,
so let me explain this to folks.
When I got there,
you have this FJ 40 which is this a Toyota
jeep like vehicle from the 1960s and
seventies. And what you've
done is, oh actually they
went deep into the 80s right.
With that shame early eighties the,
that you've made a
completely new version of it.
So it is sort of an FJ 40 but there's
nothing that's really from an Fj 40 you've
just got the shape that you've completely
had remanufacturer in a in a beautiful
new aluminum.
So we keep sort of core components so
that we can still justify an illegal front
that it is a resto mod but it
has with color resto mod fuck it.
Structural portion of the
firewall, bib, hinge, headlight,
Bezel, pedal back a couple
of things. It's a joke.
That's why we're hoping to get this law
passed cause cause then you don't need
the old car. We can purpose build
it. This is so fucking pray.
The fjs traditionally had rust issues
so we crafted out of 60 61 aluminum.
But the way that body shape we can get
away with pretty crude construction
techniques with the rover,
there's things about it that you couldn't
so you could reinterpret it and then
you're probably up legal creek with Land
Rover that you'd have to negotiate and
come to terms with.
The other issue is even the tooling,
as primitive as it might be for the Fj,
if I was the only geek using those bodies,
I could have never made a business model
for the amortization of the development
cost of the tools needed to make it so
other companies that run the company that
makes, it's called
rubbish. They're in Canada,
they have a fairly significant market
of which I'm probably a minority too,
which guys buy them and
build their own thing or
this thing is so incredible,
which, and looking at the video,
this defender one 10 with
the internal sub frame,
you're into the edit j video now. Oh, this
afternoon. Okay. Is this the Fj 44 yup.
Okay, so this is a four door, four door
version, which didn't really exist. Right?
This is also something
that you've created. Yeah.
It just never made sense
to us that it didn't,
back in those days when Toyota did do a
four door wagon version, Land Cruiser,
the body style had nothing to do with
the 40 I always thought the 40 would be
cool as a four door and actually
there's a 40 that's a two data.
A client on the phone,
it was ready to rock and his wife suffers
shoulder saying you can't have it.
If you can't take the kids with you
on the weekend, you ain't getting it.
So this is when we were a little bit
hungrier earlier on with the brand.
I did a quick and dirty like South Park
Quality Photoshop rendering turn one
into a four door, punted it to him and
she's like, you can get one of those.
So I'm like, all right. So I winged
it on what the costs were going to be.
Lost some money on it, but it took that
design and made it our next new model.
And then now it's, it's, it's our
most popular cause six passengers.
If this law passes and you can sort
of just build your own vehicles,
do you anticipate ever just
building something completely
from scratch? Yes. Yeah.
I mean,
part of me is challenging myself
because like I mentioned earlier,
a big part of why what I do now is
appealing to people is that people already
have history and story and
emotions tied to these vehicles.
But I have other stupid ideas that are
like based on theoreticals of like if the
industrial revolution hadn't happened
when it happened and streamlined art
moderne continued to prosper
and develop as a design style,
where, what would that final ultimate
vision be? I want to build that car,
but much harder to market it
because no one has an affinity.
It's called the Helio's, um, based
on the creek God of the wind.
And it's, I would design it to
fit on the new test, the platform.
And it's like if Howard
Hughes drank too many,
he didn't drink apparently,
but if he got drunk with Buck Minister
fueler and Gordon pure record,
two great designers, what would that
Napkin sketch of look like? It's like,
what would he have taken Corella Deville
to the country club in big gnarly
aircraft and the spired burnished
aluminum leather straps,
a little bit of steam punk,
a little bit of aerospace hot Rod
Tesla audacious thing to build it.
That sounds awesome. Yeah, I'm, I'm
in. I like it. I love it. These, these,
these designs,
you know,
I think a big part of what you're saying
is definitely true that people have
this connection to these particular
shapes that they fell in love with,
like the Fj 40 like the Bronco.
But I think that your company
also is developing that on
its own. You're, you're,
you're developing your own sort of
following. Thank you. Yeah, so I set out,
I think you're right. I think long
term that's better. Like right now,
if I did a vehicle holy of our own design,
the titling process follows that of
like a kit car, which is not scalable.
So if, if that law evolves, I'm, I'm
all in. I got tons of stupid ideas.
Yeah, that's a weird thing. Right? Like
the, the kit car thing, that's like,
they would sell a lot of those like the
uh, the noble, the noble, which I sell.
What does that mean? It's
an English car, right? Yeah.
And then they just get the body and you
have to buy a roller and then you have
to have another duty to
put the drive training.
Or what's crazier is still is
the way the laws are currently,
and this bill we're trying to get past
is literally just the combination of
existing laws saying, look,
this is all out there,
but right now companies can't do it.
So if some dude in his backyard has some
spare two by fours and some corrugated
sheeting and a VA,
he can hack together a death trap,
take it down. If it has turn signals, tail
lights and basic stuff, he's good to go.
If a company were to build that
same assemblage, it's not legal.
So it's just asinine because the
companies are going to have the technical
resources, the financial wherewithal,
the accountability, et Cetera,
to create a safer, better, more conscious
product. So it makes no sense to me.
That's why we're hoping it will make
sense to Congress because we know how good
they are efficiently
reviewing and passing things.
That'll further our nation's interest.
At least on paper.
The companies have
enough money to do that.
There's the the leap right from the
initial investment to putting together an
actual car, but it's so much cheaper now.
What do you got there? That's the Helios.
Oh,
it's gotten so much more cost
effective and viable to bring out.
Highly engineered, no compromise.
High quality, low volume product.
Is this anywhere online
where Jamie can pull this up?
This is one of the coolest
things I've ever seen.
Send send this to Jane where which,
where's the Google icon? Helio's, H, e l.
I. O. S and it'll pop right up. This
is sick. You'd sell a million of these,
five of the things. You're going to build
that thing and we tried to suicides,
attention. His engineering team
drafted a letter and send it to me.
He was so sweet. That title was
like peanut butter for chocolate,
begging Ilan to support this.
Not on a branded level,
but give us a meal.
Tesla and the technological,
the the engineering support to repurpose
the Tesla in this unique platform.
But we never got his attention.
Somebody needs to get ahold of him please.
I don't,
I'm not saying Twitter,
Bama but Twitter but I'm just ready
for whoever wants to support it at this
point. I'll do it. Electric gas or diesel.
I just need to see it fucking built
cause it's just keeps me awake.
That's so beautiful. And
the, again the suicided,
that's Howard's original experimental
planes stunt plane that he built his topic
age. Wine too. I like the
original version of the things.
That's a series of panels
showing inspirations that
we start with a fuselage of
the plane.
Then we roll it into road going form.
Then we start to do the packaging
factors and the kid kept evolving.
Wow. God this is fucking
crazy. Deal panels,
Sun roofs that are on cranks with
exposed gear and leather ratchet.
So there's like that somewhat steam
punk interface of the mechanical power
windows seem deal. I want
like brass cure. See,
see the gears rotate as well as Dale.
I love it.
I love the little leather covered dash
to the hand stitched dash and the rivets.
If I had the cash, this thing would
already be under construct. Fuck,
I just built it for myself.
But you know all these rich dudes,
it seems like someone would have
already dove into this. Totally.
This is a no lose. This is gorgeous,
but it's expensive. Oh yeah.
Well no profit.
This thing would still cost me probably
1.31 point 4 million just to deny it
first right now like yeah,
I could make it look good and everything
but like engineered finite analyze like
balls out done.
It'd be at least 1.1 call you Texas friend
that wanted a chainsaw. That Ferrari
in half. Let's see. He only likes Ferraris
because everybody knows what a frog.
So that's another promise.
Some dudes look at this and go yet,
but it's not the Bentley.
So those people need to eat dick.
They really do all of them.
Why are you being like that all at least
in and my friend, money's no option.
Exclusivity.
I had recently in Encino,
I was driving one of our things and this
like stereotypical Armenian guy with,
you know, the big gold and the loafers
and the whole night. Nice. He leans over,
he looks in peaks in the
window. It goes props, but all,
I thought that was killer. It
was really cool. Armenians, man,
I love how they just
wear it on their sleeve.
There's one of my favorite people
and they're like, don't fuck with me.
I am what I am and I'm
going to protect the baby.
They're not trying to change at all.
Gold chains. Fucking flying high go baby.
Yeah. This is a beautiful thing,
man, to creating things like this is,
this is beautiful. I love
it. It's a dream. I'm stoked.
I'm glad you're doing it.
I just think it's so important.
It's so important that someone out there
is creating these bizarre creations,
these, these even more important,
someone's buying them. Yes,
but they're gonna be doing it. But I'd
be doing it in my garage at my house.
And just kind of wanting to tell.
And the fact that you put out,
like we said early, you put out all these
videos and you put all these, these,
these images, even if people aren't,
they don't have the cash to buy him.
People get inspired. But what you're
doing, oh fucking for sure. 100%.
Tell me how much is it like a
defender to reengineer? Cause I,
your video is very extensive.
Like you had to reengineer price.
How much is something like
that cost? Ah, the defenders,
the d 90 and the one time
we've done two so far, uh,
anywhere from 250 to low,
400,000.
And that's a car angel.
And I have to tell somebody that,
but these people that you are building
these nuts, they're just crazy.
And they go, well yeah I've tried it this
way. I one built by and, but these all,
they suck. I get what you do. Just do it.
So most people who would do a Matthew
Perlman's, great guy, he's a guy,
does west coast defenders, met them,
hung out with them and seen his shop.
What he's doing is rebuilding
them. Exactly. But brand
new, smarter than me. But,
but what you're doing,
you're reengineering everything.
Is there anybody out there re he
reengineering everything, the suspension,
the subframe, the, the way the,
the floor is sealed and polyuria coded
and you're just tying it to a stupid
level. Um, I guess singer,
singer and then arch motorcycles.
Mm.
Um,
those guys I'd say are on par with
rethinking every little nuance and going
balls out on it. If you ever heard, have
you met those guys down in Long Beach?
And it's a Keanu Reeves
and um, um, ah, man,
I can't remember his name.
He's a sweetheart, um,
guard, guard, guard and Kiana, his
company. And they're doing a lovely,
lovely, lovely job. Now
it's to a guy like you,
Google auto drive cars have to be the
devil. Yes. That's the devil. It is.
What's going to happen?
Are we gonna we're gonna not be able
to drive our own cars in the future.
Is that a possibility?
You know,
I've been thinking long and hard about
that and it's been something that um,
different people in my sub culture have
openly been concerned and discussing and
there's many different takes on it,
but I think I'm pretty centered on it.
I think actually it's a positive thing
and that cars is like the Prius and
stuff,
you know,
started the generation where people
don't have an emotional relationship with
their vehicle. It's a tool. It's
literally like an APP on your phone.
It gets you from a to B or even
more dispassionately. Screw it.
You Uber around and you don't care.
You don't have that relationship.
So I think culturally as autonomous
vehicles and all that continue to grow and
evolve, you are going to see them
eventually become predominant.
And I think we're going to start to see
lobbying and federal support of that
direction because there's
a lot of rational reasons
behind it. That being said,
I think it will further strengthen the
demand for the freaks and the Geeks,
the outliers such as my brand because
people are going to yearn for that
relationship, that attachment, and I
think there's always going to be people.
Even the guy who's got the autonomous
Mercedes at that says commuter,
but on the it's like, oh no,
I mean this thing's got to,
it's caught a manual transmission
and there's, there's,
there's pedals by the way,
and there's three of those pedals and
you have to push that one down to get it
to, you know, I think there,
there's that visceral relationship that
is always going to be part of mankind
and I'm not worried about it. If I
was trying to start a big car company,
then I would be worried about it.
American muscle cars are one of the
only companies that are sticking to that
manual transmission model.
I mean some cars like the z 28 and
the like up until this version of the
corvette,
you couldn't get the high end corvette
and anything but a manual like the Zr one
admissions laws are screwing that pooch
because it's so much harder for them to
certify a manual car than an
automatic cause. The automatic,
the shifts cycles and efficiencies are
much easier to track and to regulate and
pretense for in the programming
and engineering dynamics
of the car. So that's,
it's an emissions issue more
than anything. Also nowadays,
the odd today's automatics are
quicker than of course, man.
Well that's the Porsche deal. I mean
the, the version of what that car public,
sure.
As to why,
but the real answer is based on emissions
and efficiency as far as gas and fuel
consumption control over efficiency
more than honest efficiency because you
manual driven, right?
You can make it work.
I mean the CVT train constant velocity.
Everyone said how amazing they were
going to be for efficiency and there's,
you know, they work with the snowy
tears. Yeah, it's an automatic,
but it's like if you picture a cone form,
it's spins out.
So the ratio is constantly changing
as you go through your speed cycles,
but seemed like a great idea, but at
the end of the day and true world use,
they realize, oh yeah, no,
it was incredibly inefficient
just to spoil the fucker.
You were deficit of 10%
and your fuel economy.
So I think it'll,
it'll hopefully shift back and like how
many more gears can they shoved in our
automatic to try and meet
emissions as well. Yeah,
they're going to eight now and they're
doing seven, seven with manuals now too,
which is weird. Pain in the ass. It's
just, it's an awkward pattern, but again,
it's a business case, right? It's
a hell of a lot easier to add.
Shove a couple more gears to keep that
motor in it tighter, more controlled,
more predictable rpm band than it is
to evolve and keep engineering internal
combustion.
Make it better for all of your motor runs.
So hesitant to do that until it's
regulated or competition forces that
transition.
It's just,
to me it's a bummer that a lot of these
sports cars at the very least are going
by Norberg ring times and there they want
zero to 60 times and not how they make
you feel. Yeah, but that's what
a sports car, it's always been.
Most of the Times driving, you're not,
you're not counting laps when you're a,
you're on little by little to hunger.
Rather, you're not looking for laptops.
You're looking for pure enjoyment
and if you're shifting the gears,
you're going to get more enjoyment because
you're going to be more connected to
the experience. Totally.
But, and more than that too,
like drove a 97 nine nine three 12 turbo
to a friend's House to drive his new
50th anniversary,
nine 11 sexy car bitch and colors,
beautiful tactile surfaces.
Cool tweet. You tried it.
It doesn't feel like a Porsche to me.
There's so many distractions and knobs
and widgets and Gizmos and switches and
alarms and babysitters and lawyers on
board versus that nine, nine, three yet.
It's radically, yeah. Can
shake your teeth. Yes.
It can blow your eardrums out when you
drunk Indian nail it, whatever it is,
what it is. It had purity of
purpose and I think many brands,
but most notably automotive brands have
fallen prey to focus groups where they
try and create a product that appeals
to this mythical large demographic of
everyone's going to love it, which in
turn I think they step on there we we,
because it doesn't speak to any one,
it doesn't have clarity,
purpose in its engineering and design.
It doesn't have the balls to say,
I'm not for everyone.
This is what I do and I do it damn well.
Not only that,
it doesn't appeal to automotive
enthusiasts. It appeals to people.
That might not be the same thing. The you
could say the same thing about sitcoms.
You could say the same thing.
Movies.
When someone creates
something odd and unique,
it's very difficult for
other people to agree to it.
If they give it to a focus group or a
heart for the poor bastard producer,
writer it actually sell it
because everyone wants to
dumb it down to the largest
common denominator, the formula
they were able to sell to the ads.
You know the advertisers last season
or what that company's doing a whatever
catwalk show. Well let's do a dog
walk, whatever it is and yeah,
well isn't that the case Wa or one of
the best examples for why a business like
yours works is it's you and your wife.
I mean it's you, it's you and your,
and I think that singular vision is
consumers are ganging up to demand that
thank goodness,
but I mean you tick,
I've always said you take like
every modern four door sedan,
car paying all of them black,
take all the fucking emblems off,
put them on a big empty airplane hangar,
bringing it thousand of the general
public car geeks and not ask them to name
all these cars. Well who makes them,
which brand they are. But you know,
one would get better than a d plus
because they're all copying each other and
all trying to not be too out land issue.
Too unique or too different.
All they're doing is making their
blink bigger. The grills bigger,
the emblem larger, and it's like
there's a loss of, of, of, uh,
of individualism.
Well,
there's only a few that you
could recognize based on
sort of the iconic grills
like BMWs. They have those too. Like
jeeps, you can kind of recognize those.
But boy, there's a Hyundai that looks
just like a fucking Mercedes now. I mean,
I've seen it many times.
I thought it was a Mercedes and it's hard.
It's that look like Aston Martins
and on and on. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a lot of that going on right
now. There's a lot of like, boy,
if this was the music business,
you might get fucking sued. You're,
you're stealing notes.
Right? Totally. Do you,
is there anything that excites you
about modern automobiles that they're
creating now? Is there anything
that you find that it is a positive?
You had a lot of them.
Mechanical engineering is mindblowing
electromagnetic suspension system.
I'm finding quite interesting
and hoping to start dabbling in.
Yeah, constantly. What did,
I just think a lot of it's superfluous
and promoting self obsolescence.
So I'm like always cautious, but
I mean, I'm not immune to it.
So like I'll lease a crazy
new car once in a while,
but I'll do a one year or
two year leash and I'll,
I'll put it in its place like
it's so complex. It's Asinine.
It's going to fall apart. But
right now is really fun, you know?
But usually like within six months I'm
bored because it has no soul and then I
lose my ass and move on. Well, we'll
hop back in my desoto what I, yeah,
well there's a total difference in the
what? That you're aware you're doing it.
Whereas like the Lexus,
I love my big Lexus truck because it's,
Oh yeah, it's floats over
everything and it's just bone quiet.
It's just woo smooth.
But you're not experiencing
it the way you experience,
say like one of your fjs or
something like that. So, I mean,
I've got a lot of clients who maybe
daily they're going to hop in that Lx for
the boring commute,
but then when they really want to engage
or with the themselves, the vehicle,
the family of the hobby,
the locale,
then they're going to hop in the
icon and they're going to be,
it's more of an experience.
One of the things that I like about you
and what you're doing with your company
is you as a person,
you have this broad variety of interests
and respects for cultures and various
things, and I noticed the from
following your Instagram, but you,
you do a lot of trips and he'd take a
lot of trips to these different cultures.
Are you doing this because this
is something you personally enjoy?
Are you like consciously trying
to enrich yourself like, yeah,
it's always been priority number
one. I think as a, as Americans,
we have a bad habit of having blinders
on and not understanding there's the shit
that we get all es or panties in a
knot about mean absolutely nothing.
On the opposite side of the coin.
I think progress is a
misrepresented benefit to mankind.
I've been to some remote cultures where
I think those people are a hell of a lot
more balanced and centered and
family focused and healthy.
Um, then we are in our
progress. So I liked,
I love traveling. It's super
important to me. And as a designer,
um,
understanding different cultures,
approaches to solutions complex or
simple or use of color and texture and
materials. It just enriches
what I do to, to no end.
But I think it's, it's really a much
bigger picture life thing. Like, um,
it's gotten more expensive
now I have two teenage signs,
but like we'll travel less but we'll,
we'll still make sure that to do those
trips and bring the kids at least half
the time. So you know, we, they
have that, that perspective.
Yeah. Then the enrichment is sort
of, it's not like calculable,
you can't like put it
on a scale. Like, Hey,
we should go to Africa
because it's worth this.
It just changes the way you
see the world and how you,
when you make eye contact with someone,
what you're expecting out of that person
or what's your open to experiencing
from that person.
I think travelers open themselves up to
such a crazy greater level to be able to
embrace and experience and you just
never know what's going to happen.
And what one trip or handshake or
eye contact will turn into them.
I'm on the board of this kickass
charity called go campaign.
You should come one year. We do a really
fun cars and casino night at the shop.
When do you do it? Joel Mchale
was our host this year. We
do it the first weekend.
Amaze us. We love him to one
of my favorite humans. Um,
so you know we were in,
in Africa a couple of weeks ago and yeah,
we were doing the safari
camping glamping thing,
but we were in Tanzania because we're,
we're starting a big fundraiser
this year with go, um,
to create a new center like
children's center. Cause, um,
if you have physical or
mental disabilities in many
African cultures, it's,
it's frightening what
happens. So there's, um,
there's ways to impact the
world outside of buildings,
silly cars for rich guys. But
both experiences, you know,
doing something for a children's
center, Tanzania, those relationships,
those experiences all helped
me gain a different and better,
hopefully more valuable perspective on
everything down to how I'm going to build
a car or what material we're going to use.
So I think what we were talking about
earlier about teaching inspiration in
school and you know, teaching people
how to think and how to fall passion,
that it's a lacking component.
I think you could also say these sort
of the same thing about traveling and
experiencing different cultures
exchange program. It's not richer.
It's not as appreciated.
Or as, as, as um, uh,
what's the word? Um, it's not as
encouraged, you know, it's what it is.
Well and sadly enough to, unfortunately
nowadays a lot of your global travels,
you might as well be at the third street
promenade in Santa Monica or Paris or
Barcelona or wherever because this big
box commoditize the tourist experience
has become this kind of homologated
experience that's one size fit on you.
It's the gap or whatever. It's the same
box stores and think more and more.
It's like Disneyland travel unless
you really work hard at it to find the
culture in the people, so
that's kind of scary. Yeah,
you got to really go looking
for it. I found all of
garden, the Sao Paulo airport,
so they go, sorry, olive garden,
but you see like what Detroit
is doing in the airport.
They did a great example of this hopeful,
this renaissance I speak of and hope
they kicked out all the generic bullshit,
typical airport concessionaire
food, Chili's, brands,
all that crap.
Right?
Then they invited in local
restaurant tours, local chefs,
local craft beer makers, gave
them all killer deals. He said,
come and rich,
our airport communicate Detroit,
why people should be in Detroit.
The Passion, the craft of Detroit.
Be a part of that,
which is just killer.
It's my friend's restaurant just got put
in there and he's super stoked. It's,
it's, it's, it's a win win. Detroit
was depressing when I was there,
but one of the things that was kind
of cool was that I was seeing like a
resurgence of all these very small sort
of craft businesses and that'll be the
only thing that'll ever save Detroit,
in my humble opinion. And he has,
you get past the topical depression.
It's a very inspiring place.
Yeah. There's, there's,
there's opportunity because the real
estate is insanely cheap and there's, you
know, there's young people and young
people or young people everywhere,
they have hopes and passions and they,
they have the internet and
they look around, they go,
that's a fucking building right here,
man. Let's just do this. And boom. Yeah.
Let me look what Shinola is done. Am
I, I dunno, which I know have done. Oh,
should I know this is cool brand that
does watches and I thought it was like,
Shit. I know. I thought what
it's like a term that's,
that's where they got the new shoe Polish.
It was back a pre World War II and
that's where they got the name from it.
You don't know shit from Shinola.
They're parallel being more
product with purpose and story.
So like, Oh, you bought that, you don't
know shit from Shinola. This is Shinola.
A watch. Oh, it started as a watch.
Then they own Filson.
Then they've got a wonderful
American northwest cultural icon,
leather goods outdoors company.
So yeah, they, they do, uh,
bags and watches and bicycles and
leather goods and they're getting into
notebooks and all sorts of stuff.
But their whole thing is the cultural
renaissance of Detroit supporting Detroit.
They're opening up facilities in old worn
out industrial buildings, re-purposing.
I'm training local kids to
build it like their watches.
They're assembling their own movements
in Detroit and training people because
there wasn't a skillset for it.
So it's those efforts times a
billion at companies large and small,
that are the future of our
country. And I think, uh,
most poignantly with Detroit near term.
Well.
It's one of those things
I think that when you,
you see like a lack of opportunity.
You see people sort of try to
create their own opportunities.
He engineered by either stealing
the copper out of your building
Sao Paulo style, steal your
car, redistribute wealth
problem solved or yeah,
like stopping and thinking and engage.
You can't find a job. Make a job. Yeah.
Well Detroit has a real problem with them
stealing pipes and stuff that they're
doing that from a lot of buildings,
rain,
but I just do love the fact that
when you've, you find a dip,
like we were talking about with
Cuba where they don't have any cars,
so let's just figure out a way to make
these fucking cars weren't making it work
and what you're seeing in a lot of these
other places where there's not a lot of
great jobs,
there's not a lot,
so they're creating their own
possibilities and creating that.
It's happened for so long that it's become
a source of pride for their culture,
which then makes it that
much more important. Exactly.
Exactly. Exactly. Listen man,
you've got a busy company
to run and I really,
really appreciate your time and I'm sure
you have a lot of stuff you have to get
done,
but it is important to do and I really
appreciate you taking the time to really
come to the shop and kind of
really understand or lunacy and uh,
it's an awesomely impressive, awesomely
impressive and inspirational. Uh,
anybody who's interested, Icahn
four by four, four x four.com,
a four x four on Twitter, right? Um,
and then, um, Tlc,
which is your Toyota Land
Cruiser Restoration Company is a,
what does that Tlc, TLC
four x four.com. Okay.
And then the inside scoop on
our Facebook has just my name,
cause it's totally not
corporate and unprofessional,
but a hell of a lot more fun or an icon.
Icon.
Customs is your Twitter handle? I'm
sorry. It's not ICAHN. Four x four.
It's icon customs ICAHN, four x
four.com is the website. Thank you man.
Really appreciate it. It's a lot of fun.
Sure. Jonathan Ward, ladies and gentlemen.
Yeah.